you know the olympics this is a time
guys
where two or three days away from the
opening ceremonies
people are starting to get excited i
can't even imagine
how nbc executives must be freaking out
they're looking at 7000 hours of
coverage
which they had planned in tokyo but
there's a chance that this thing might
not even happen even a couple days
coveted cases are rising a little bit
it's all relative but you know
everybody's freaking out because you
have so many media members over there so
anything's a big deal
the big thing though is with the women's
gymnastics team and that's simone biles
right and she is
she is what a uh nbc's going to be
hanging their hat on she's going to be
the biggest star at the olympics and now
the alternate one of the alternates on
the
women's gymnastics team tested positive
so
you know what what do you think right
now gerard as far as the level of
apprehension for nbc
for ioc officials because on tuesday the
head of the olympics in japan said
there's no guarantee these games are
happening yeah and i think that's that's
i feel so so terrible for uh
athletes in general that have dedicated
their entire lives for four years for
this moment and now they have to have
this apprehension like
you know the countdown this this is the
payoff you know we all we all practice
you know like iverson said it best
practice you know it's the worst people
people don't like practicing i you know
i've told this story before on the pbd
podcast
when i was with the cardinals in the
minor leagues one of their big things
was embrace the suck
embrace the suck like it sucks don't
think that people think
because you're playing a game like
everything that you do about that game
is
is fun it's not most of being a pro
athlete is pretty terrible
right it really is but then when you get
that opportunity to perform under the
lights there's nothing on earth like it
so
my heart is just kind of going out for
the athletes and i'm hoping everything
goes
goes smoothly and goes on without it
it's a roller coaster ride it's
unbelievable
they already had it delayed one year
right so then they had to alter all
their training and their travel and
everything
but you want to see some of the stories
out there the media is really bitching
too because
so many of the media members who had any
sort of contact tracing
they're being quarantined for 14 days in
their hotel they're getting no food sent
to them they're on their own they're
ordering japanese pizza i don't even
know what
where you get that how you get that you
know tokyo had 1300 cases
on tuesday in a city of 13 million
you know they've got a state of
emergency right now it's it's just crazy
do you look forward to the olympics jeff
are you gonna be bumped if these don't
happen
i'm a big olympic guy i think my error
older guys is something
cachet right about the olympics so uh
my feeling the olympics is gonna happen
it's going forward
come hell or high water full speed ahead
am i looking forward to it
absolutely you know what i i i don't
watch nbc that much anymore right i
don't watch network tv
so i haven't seen the promos i haven't
really gotten caught up in it
so i'm not that excited i think it's one
of those things once you start watching
it
you do do you think do you think nbc
will put any pressure
on and i'm being serious about this do
you think they'll put any pressure on
olympic officials
to maybe misplace simone bile's coveted
test
um but they can't afford to have her
test positive
are you are you possibly claiming
that this could somehow be manipulated
for personal gain in some way or another
they can't afford to not have her front
and center listen man
you know i look man we're starting this
thing off hot man we're starting this
thing
you can give me a yes or no and i'll get
you off the hook here no look i mean
come on man
like dude what are we doing here you
know how many how many
in shape 24 year olds have been
seriously affected by this that we're
we're at some point this is at some
point this is performative at some point
this is
you know health theater at some point
man like look
anybody who didn't anybody who didn't
want to be exposed they had the
opportunity to opt out when everybody
opted it they signed up for this they
knew what they
they knew what they were risking and
they said let's do it anyway man like
let's compete
dude like i i don't i don't know i i
really uh
at some point man i i think we're all
adults
we're all consenting and if people went
over there then went over there to
compete let them compete i hope you
enjoyed that short clip from episode two
of sports now with tom zenner there's
more where that came from here's another
short clip for you to click on from
episode 2
or episode 2 in its entirety right here
and don't forget to subscribe to
valuetainment sports